stéphane ravier nous a rejoint également
en direct stéphane ravier sénateurs you
rassemblement national des bouches du
rhône bonsoir monsieur ravier merci
bonjour on dirait cela avec nous sur
arte france vous faites partie de ceux
qui défendent et qui défendent pardon le
ardemment en tout cas le maintien de cet
article 24 n'est ni je le défends nuit
je le condamne cet article 24 en réalité
est un coup médiatique de la part du
ministre de l'intérieur parce que de
protéger la vie des policiers cela
existait déjà dans notre législation
on peut très bien traîner devant les
tribunaux celles et ceux qui menacent la
vie de la police d'un policier et et
faire fermer des sites qui diffusent des
images de policiers qui inciterait un
super et à la violence
ça existe déjà dans notre dans notre
code mais le parquet le parquet classe
classe les affaires classe les plaintes
c'est bien là le problème
alors ce cet article en fois c'était un
article de puces mais qui était censé
surtout faire la promotion sécuritaire
du ministre de l'intérieur une une
offensive sécuritaire qui s'est effondré
sous le poids de la rue mais la rue je
le dis ce n'est pas la france
ce qui casse aujourd'hui est ce qui
empêche les commerçants de travailler
alors que cela fait des mois qu'ils sont
à l'agonie
ce sont les milices d'extrême gauche et
anarchiste qui sont pourtant très bien
connu des services qui sont connus de la
préfecture de police de paris
mais que le pouvoir la faire car le
pouvoir joue sur un équilibre de la peur
cela a été dit sur votre antenne et je
suis tout à fait d'accord
le président de la république veut
apparaître comme celui qui tient le pays
alors qu'il y met le feu le sait c'est
lui qui laisse les violences se
développer pour apparaître comme le
garant de l'unité
or c'est un président qui divise c'est
un président qui fracturent il va bien
falloir que les français que la france
réelle retournent aux urnes car il n'y a
que ça pour changer la france ce n'est
pas la violence ce n'est pas la casse
ce n'est pas l'agression vers les
policiers qui font difficile métier moi
je les soutiens le seul moyen d'en
sortir c'est d'aller aux urnes et de
changer la donne
en changeant bien sûr de personnel
politique et vous imaginez où vous
comprenez acquis à qui je pense